[Music]
thank you since well I've seen you here
and there yeah but the time that we
spend the most time was actually your
wedding yeah you came to our wedding
thank you for inviting you're welcome we
only had five get it was a lovely it was
at the at the hotel that was based on
the shiny yep which was terrified yeah I
wanted so badly to see a ghost but I
didn't I was kind of hoping that your
ring bearer would be like the girl doing
the backwards crab walk with the ring on
her belly
I won't yeah she's scary
don't I know it
I saw it recently and there's the scene
I don't want to make it worse for you by
making you imagine but she crab walks
down the stairs sorry does a handstand
that's fun and she vomits then the the
girlfriend at the time my girlfriend at
the time turned to me
[Laughter]
no weird weird she's great
how is your husband your husband rich
wrote on the pilot this show is one of
the reasons you text oka
you texted me thinking it was rich yeah
and I hope you don't mind I actually
took a screenshot of that text so we
actually have it I love you beep see you
were a real fart monster this morning
yeah do you remember that morning do I
do I was sitting at like the corner
bakery yeah I do remember that wedding
there and I don't want you to think that
mr. Blom cake has a problem with his
farts but it was just a particular - a
festive morning yes but it doesn't end
there you texted that and then it came
in that was not for you oh my god okay
don't tell rich
clearly you were the worst person to sin
that I didn't tell rich BBS it happen I
love the blonde quake and that's real
intimacy is when you know he just
letting them out you can't be open and
fart in front of the person it's like
the next level of the friendships right
you know if you can't do that or be like
I'm gonna go take a [ __ ]
all that [ __ ] was aware of that's just a
whole nother side of you as a human I
met an actress once and who I'm not
gonna say her name but she's very famous
and she's married to a famous actor and
they'll be crazy no and she said that
she doesn't talk about that in front of
him Jennifer Garner doesn't
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]